who's by the way lurking in the shadows
trying to catch you you've mentioned FBI
Secret Service you you mentioned uh I
think I've heard you mentioned US
Marshals which is interesting cops
General the police CIA I guess CIA is
international only FBI is internal yes
okay well so who is when you're doing
this who are you afraid of so by the
time I've gotten to Atlanta within four
or five days the FBI raided my office I
guess I kind of missed that back in
Florida back in Florida when I left and
drove to Atlanta and left remember this
FBI was going to show up a few days
later they were going to arrest me and
they did they did they showed up like I
left on a Sunday night or something
because for some reason in my
stupid thought I thought well they won't
arrest me on the weekend like they don't
work on the weekends um so they came on
like a whatever it was like a Tuesday or
Wednesday or Thursday like within a few
days they come in the office they rate
it they're looking for me but I'm gone
nobody knows where I am and uh so now
I'm I'm surveying the homeless guys and
I turn around and I'm ordering their
documents and as their documents are
showing
up you know I'm I'm going to different
states and getting
IDs so I'm going to Florida so over over
the course of this whole thing I've had
27 driver's licenses in like seven
different states I've had two dozen
passports because if you're going to get
the driver's license in the guy's name
you might as well get or an ID even you
might as well get a passport because a
passport is not difficult to get they
don't fingerprint you you know all they
look all they're doing is saying this is
your ID and where you're born here and
then they run a check and if it it comes
back or it doesn't and back then you
could do it expedited and I'd have it in
like two weeks like now it takes like 90
days or 60 to 90 days to get one but and
if you have multiple ideas for a sing
sing identity that's more proof like
right so wait what number did you say
how many how many IDs how many
identities so I had well I've had over
50 identities but I've had
27 driver's licenses issued from State
DMVs Department of Motor Vehicles so
like legitimately legitimately I walked
into the DMV said hi my name is Michael
eert and I just moved here about three
weeks ago four weeks ago here's my lead
and here I I I lost my I lost my
driver's license bro like I don't know
what I did with it I don't know I don't
know what happened I I don't know and
they're like it's all right uh what do
you have do you have I need a proof of
residency well I have my lease oh okay
um I need a a a primary uh okay here's
my birth certificate okay and I need a a
a secondary here's my social security
card but I also registered you know I I
registered to vote my girlfriend made me
vote immediately and she said I would
need oh yeah it's perfect you're you're
good I don't even need that okay great
stand over there pay that person they
call your number 275 you know 45 minutes
later you go you pay your 25 bucks you
stand in front of the the screen they
take a picture you got a driver's
license you walk out it's still warm
it's beautiful it smells like pop
plastic it's amazing and so I I'm
opening up
different uh different bank accounts in
these guys
names and just what yeah sorry well what
are you mostly doing with the identities
opening up different bank accounts are
you doing a credit uh starting to
establish credit or no some of them like
I might order um I might
order uh secured credit cards so I can't
get credit you know I'm building their
credit like it's not helping me in any
way I'm just sending out $500 to get a a
Capital One card or a American I'm sorry
A Bank of America secured credit card
whatever so I'm building their credits
but not all of them only a few because
I'm collect although I'm collecting
them I'm also going to be moving soon
I'm only here to get a few $100,000 and
move I need some kind of a base so I
don't want to start getting credit cards
and building up a a history in Atlanta
in anybody's name but I am getting
driver's licenses in other states so I'm
been like North Carolina South Carolina
what's the primary method of income here
when you move to a place South Carolina
how do you make a 100 ,000 at this at
this time oh well I'm right now I'm
living in this guy's house and I
satisfied his loans the house is worth
200,000 got it so what happens is one
day we go and we check public records
remember I told you it takes months for
it to show up and it shows up he's got
no mortgages on the house so now I'm I
turn around and I make a fake ID in the
name Michael
Shanahan and I'm living in his house but
I have no credit right there's no credit
so I've got a the the ID I I've got a a
social security number and I order some
secure credit cards in his name so if
you pull that credit profile it does it
shows up saying he's got some credit
cards but it's they've only they're only
a month or two old so I can't go to like
Bank of America I mean I
could
but I needed to get the money as quick
as possible like I I want to get out of
Atlanta so and at this point by the way
there's multiple articles showing up in
Tampa so the St Petersburg times is is
writing multiple articles about me with
your face with my picture yeah but it's
honestly it's it's pre I not pre-
internet but it's it's post internet but
it's it's in its infancy like no
nobody's it's not huge and and honestly
it's a it's a it's a it's a local
newspaper in Tampa it's not that big of
a deal like I'm not concerned about that
so much at this point what I'm concerned
about is getting a chunk of money and
just moving on and kind of
reestablishing ourselves in a better way
where we're not living in a in a
building that we're going to be
committing fraud in with or house so but
I'm living in this place I make a fake
ID in the name Michael Shanahan and I
call up three secured or sorry three
hard money lenders a hard money lender
is a guy that lends his own money or
other investors money on property kind
of like a bank but he's lending his own
money so he doesn't have to really meet
the banking
requirements and he can charge a much
higher interest rate these guys are
charging 12 13% interest uh simple
interest and they're only lending you a
a much lower percentage of the value of
your home so they're not lending you 90%
of the value they're lending you 65%
60% so I call three of these guys they
all come out to the house at different
times and each one of them says I'll
lend you 100,000 or it's like 150,000
150 like they all lend roughly
150,000 so we schedule three separate
closings none of them know about the
other person so what I do is I
close I close one loan on let's say
Monday and then one on Tuesday and then
one on whatever Wednesday or Thursday or
or they may have all been the same day
to be honest but I don't remember the
point is I go to three separate title
companies or uh real estate attorneys
and we close and I get checks for you
know after cost and everything the total
ends up being roughly
400,000 so I've got 400,000 Becky and I
run another scam in in Tallahassee
Florida and we get like 50 Grand and
plus we the 80 the 80s dwindled down to
close to nothing because we we had gone
on several vacations we went to like
Bermuda and I think we went to Jamaica
we actually stated at the rits in uh in
Jamaica so it was very nice you and
Becky so Becky turned out to be pretty
good in terms of scams on the road no
she was useless she was she was she was
horrible and she just spent money all
the time and by the what I realized too
very quickly is she's
bipolar so she's bipolar and
she's absolutely you know insane she
smokes pot all the time um did that
matter for you personally or did it
actually affect the uh how good you were
able to do the these particular scams it
was that she was the type of person that
would start an argument at 1:00 in the
morning yeah and scream at the top of
her lungs and get the cops
called okay so I can't have the police
called I can't get taken downtown and
fingerprinted I can't have the police
showing up I don't know who's really
who's looking we haven't had plastic
surgery at this point we're still
pulling money together
so
oh Becky yeah Becky's a problem
and at some point I actually we send her
to a like a psychiatrist and they they
give her um they put her on
Zoloft and she takes it for like a month
or two and then she stops taking it
she's she she thought she was all better
MH like you're not all
better
that